اقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم مخيم
عسكر القديم شرقيه مدينه نابلس بالاضافه
الى عمليه اخرى في مخيم نور شمس شرقا طول
كارما شمال الضفه الغربيه ودهمت القوات
الاسرائيليه منزلي فلسطينيين في عسكر
تتهمهما اسرائيل بتنفيذ عمليات وتستعد
ايضا لهدم منزلهما هذا واندلعت اشتباكات
مسلحه اصيب على اثرها 46 فلسطينيا معظمهم
بل معظمها نتيجه الاختناق بالغاز والرصاص
المطاطي في مخيم عسكر وفق ما نقلته وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه مشاهدينا من رام الله
معنا مراسل العربيه خالد القاسم الذي
انتهت اليه عمليه الاقتحام في مخيم عسكر
وفي ايضا مخيم نور شمس في الضفه الغربيه
خالد
نعم احمد بحسب بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي فانه
نفذ عمليتين
كبيرتين في مخيم عسكر شرق نابلس ومخيم نور
شمس شرق مدينه طولكرم البيان العسكري
الاسرائيلي قال بان هدف هذا
الاقتحام للمخيمين هو اخذ قياسات منازل
فلسطينيين متهمون متهمين بتنفيذ عمليات ضد
الجيش الاسرائيلي قتل خلالها
جندي ومستوطنه في منطقه الحمراء ايضا في
الاغوار الفلسطينيه عمليات الاقتحام للجيش
الاسرائيلي
جبهت بمواجهات واشتباكات مسلحه استمرت
لفتره قصيره خلال الليل الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن انه اعتقل مطلوبين اثنين في مخيم نور
شمس يتهم
يتهمهما بالوقوف وراء عمليات اطلاق نار ضد
اهداف اسرائيليه ولكن المصادر المحليه
قالت في طولكرم طبعا قالت بان العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه فشلت في القاء القبض
على اي من المطلوبين الفلسطينيين كما ذكرت
احمد في الخبر نجم عن عمليات الاقتحام
والمواجهات والاشتباكات اكثر من 45 اصابه
معظمها بالاختناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع
كما اعترف الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان له عن
اصابه
جندي اسرائيلي بشظايا قديفه
محليات الصنع القيت باتجاه القوات
الاسرائيليه التي اقتحمت مخيم نور شمس
وقال البيان بان الاصابه طفيفه وتم نقل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات